bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 25 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition dernier hommage à
l'écrivain michel tournier les obsèques
de l'homme de lettres en 2d cours ont
lieu aujourd'hui à l'église de choisel
en yvelines hausse de la taxe foncière
et investissements locaux le budget
primitif a été voté vendredi par le
conseil départemental le point suivre
dans cette édition
et enfin il est versailles et il a 26
ans il est peut-être le futur gagnant de
top chef
rencontre avec et xavier pincement sous
chef du restaurant gordon ramsay à
versailles et candidat dans l'émission
culinaire la plus célèbre de france et
retour sur la mort d'un grand écrivain
les obsèques de michel tournier décédé
lundi 18 janvier à l'âge de 91 ans lieu
cet après midi à l'église de choisel
dans les yvelines
le bâtiment est situé à côté du
presbytère dans lequel il résidait une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
pour lui rendre hommage aujourd'hui ses
amis sa famille mais aussi les habitants
de la commune et quelques personnalités
littéraires comme bernard pivot était
invité après la cérémonie le cercueil a
été enterré dans le cimetière situé
derrière ça d'honneur ça demeure sous un
arbre qu'il avait lui-même choisi alain
seigneur maire de choisel nous a fait
part de sa tristesse
ba aujourd'hui c'est la sépulture de
michel tournier donc sont le dernier
hommage qu'on peut lui rendre avec sa
famille de coeur
c'est nouveau et tout les habitants de
choisel puisque pour nous c'était quand
même une figure depuis plus de 50 ans
qu'il vivait à choisel et on le
rencontrait facilement donc c'est
vraiment à un moment je dirais intense
dommage pour mon convoi lui rendre
économie à présent je vous le disais en
titre vendredi dernier les 42
conseillers départementaux yvelinois ont
voté le budget primitif pour l'année
2016 le conseil a notamment voté à
l'unanimité l'augmentation du taux de la
taxe foncière
michael et demi d'euros et mélanie
poquet pour ce reportage 40 voix pour et
deux abstentions les conseillers
départementaux ont voté la hausse du
taux de la taxe foncière sur les
propriétés bâties passé de 7 58% à 12 58
une hausse de 66% représente en moyenne
125 euros par foyer
une décision justifiée par un budget de
combat selon le président du département
liés à des baisses importantes des
dotations de l'état
mais il faut que les ivoiriens
comprennent c'est c'est toute notre
mission c'est que nous essayons d'être
des élus responsables
même si nous ne sommes pas responsables
des erreurs de gouvernement mais nous
sommes responsables de la gestion la
meilleure possible dans les conditions
catastrophiques de la gestion nationale
et ça nous oblige à ses extrémités
parmi les autres décisions prises les
yvelines mais sur un budget
d'investissement 180 millions d'euros
seront destinés au collège pour la
période 2010 est 2020 la modernisation
des équipements des routes
départementales et à l'estimé à 69,2
millions pour 2016 le choix que nous
faisons bien entendu c'est de maintenir
un niveau d'investissement suffisant à
la fois pour préparer l'avenir on va pas
arrêter de construire des collèges et on
va pas sur occuper les collèges
existants pour que les enfants étudient
dans de mauvaises conditions
on va investir dans le numérique pour
les collèges
on va investir dans l'activité
économique le budget 2016 des yvelines
s'élève à près de 4 milliards
le département s'engage à rebaisser les
impôts en cas de changement politique
nationale des dotations et un mode
éducation
les épreuves du baccalauréat approche ce
week-end le palais des congrès de
versailles s'est transformé en centre
d'orientation
samedi avait lieu le salon de l'étudiant
les jeunes de 15 à 25 ans étaient
invités à venir se renseigner sur les
études les filières où les carrières
proposées avec des représentants
d'universités ou d'écoles supérieures
avec les attentats survenus en année
2015 le secteur de l'armée et de la
défense a vu son nombre d'inscription
augmentent et nous sommes allés en
savoir un petit peu plus sur cet
engouement bts ou école supérieure
classe préparatoire ou université
choisir ses études un moment pas
toujours évident samedi 23 janvier le
salon de l'étudiant de versailles a aidé
les 15 25 ans à y voir un peu plus clair
nous avons un public très familial
l'orientation c'est une préoccupation
des familles donc les parents viennent
avec leurs enfants pour rencontrer en un
seul et même lieu
beaucoup d'organismes de formation de
nombreux domaines d'études au sein des
yvelines mais aussi de la région
parisienne étaient présents le centre
d'information et de recrutement des
forces armées a passé la journée à
renseigner les jeunes tentés par le
secteur militaire
cette année l'armée enregistré une
augmentation des candidats sur le
territoire par rapport à 2014
conséquences des attentats de 2015 sur
le salon depuis maintenant plusieurs
années on constate un taux de
fréquentation très très fort pour
l'instant on est sur une orientation
andrew de 20 à 25 % de taux de
fréquentation supplémentaire petit
commente sans diplôme bac + 5
l armée attire tous les profils goût de
l'aventuré ou envie de servir son pays
les motivations sont diverses je suis
quelqu'un qui aime bien tous les métiers
qu'ils sont
les métiers d'action et donc du coup bah
je suis venu vous renseigner sur le
métier de l'armée de l'air et aussi de
la marine et de l'armée de terre suisse
pour regarder s'il ya des métiers pour
le sport un engouement qui s'explique
aussi par les nombreuses possibilités
d'évolution et la diversité des contrats
d'engagement qui s'échelonnent de 1 à 10
ans l'armée de terre prévoit ainsi de
recruter quinze mille personnes au cours
de l'année 2016 et nous accueillons ce
soir en plateau daniel varlet président
de la chambre des métiers et d'artisanat
des yvelines où l'on saura vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
l'actualité récente il a eu beaucoup
d'annoncés concernant l'économie
françois hollande a notamment annoncé un
plan d'urgence pour l'emploi
parmi ces annonces une prime d'embauché
immédiate de 2000 euros par an pour les
pme est ce que cela va changer quelque
chose pour le secteur de l'artisanat
écoutez toutes les annonces sont bons à
prendre mais faut il ya annoncé puis
après accessibilité à l'annonce
bien sûr d'embauché et d'avoir des aides
pour pour embaucher c'est bien mais il
faudrait que les secteurs et toutes
activités tous secteurs confondus est du
travail parce que suffit pas d'embauché
du monde mais si on n'a pas de travail à
leur donner c'est de notre souci premier
sur l'ensemble de l'économie de la
france non pas du département on sait
qu'il nous faut d'abord du travail et
après on pourra embaucher parce que donc
cette annonce notamment sur pour les pme
ça concerne dès aujourd'hui pour une
durée de deux ans toute entreprise de
moins de 250 salariés qui embaucheront
en cdi ou en cdd de plus de six mois
avec un salaire allant jusqu'à 1,3 fois
le smic
du coup c'est pour les petites
entreprises auxquels s'adressent les
petites les moyennes entreprises c'est
quand même le secteur d'arte scena qui
est concerné c'est dur l'artisanat est
forcément concernés maintenant que
représente 2000 euros pour un salaire
même s'il est au smic 2000 euros sur une
année
ça doit représenter même pas 10 % 2
du salaire a engagé par le par
l'entreprise et surtout sur certaines
conditions donc je pense que ceux qui
pourront en profiter tant mieux pour eux
mais c'est pas ça va pas avoir un effet
dissuasif pour nos artisans
il ya notamment la luano et donc
nouvelles opportunités économiques qui
effraie les artisans du bâtiment
est ce que vous comprenez leur crainte
forcément ils vous ont parlé parce que
le projet de texte prévoit de revoir les
qualifications nécessaires pour exercer
certains métiers c'est notamment ce à
l'objet de leur crainte donc tout à fait
raison nous avons un ensemble de
qualification qui assure la sécurité
auprès de nos clients
c'est sécurité cet apprentissage qu'on
met en amont c'est c'est technicité on
va les bafouez en mettant par le fait
que des gens vont avoir la possibilité
de faire des travaux
qu'est ce qu'il en sera derrière de la
sécurité et vis-à-vis d'après ce qui va
entraîner des malfaçons
quelle sécurité quelles garanties vont
avoir les consommateurs il nous faut des
bases et si on a travaillé dessus il
nous faut d une législation avec une
réglementation et la déréglementation
afin d'ouvrir un champ commercial est
totalement bafoués du travail qu'on a pu
faire
en un mot il est question également de
l'assouplissement du temps de travail
s'associe une mesure qui était quand
même attendu notamment par les plus
petites et moyennes entreprises
l'assouplissement du temps de travail
mais pour l'instant on n'a pas vu de
quoi elles étaient faites donc on ne
peut pas répondre sur ce sujet vous êtes
vraiment négatif par rapport justement
on n'est pas grand chose finalement
non ce sont des annonces mais qui ne
sont pas adaptés à la réalité du terrain
pour l'instant il faut qu il nous faut
des entreprises compétitives et pour
qu'elle soit compétitive il faut baisser
l'ensemble des charges des charges on a
eu quelques entreprises ont bénéficié du
cic eu par exemple qui sera je l'espère
reconduit c'était la première année 3%
sur la masse salariale c'était la
deuxième année 4%
cependant ça ne s'adressait qu'aux gens
qui avaient des salariés donc encore une
certaine
un certain nombre d'entreprises dont
nous artisans quand on sait qu'un
artisan c'est une moyenne de 1,2
employés maximum voyez que ça compte
vraiment vers le très peu de gens de
notre secteur pour 2007 vous attendait
autre chose du gouvernement par exemple
l'augmentation à des contrats de
professionnalisation c'est aussi la
question ça fait partie des choses que
vous attendez il nous faut du travail
bien sûr qu'on pourra embaucher du monde
on pourra avoir
on pourra s'engager à partager à
partager le travail à partir moment que
l'on a le travail pour l'instant nous
sommes nous sommes sinistrés nous
n'avons pas suffisamment de travail nous
donc un artisan ne va pas ne va pas
embaucher si l'apa en face matière à
donner à eux devra donner à son employé
quels sont les enjeux pour la chambre
des métiers d'art point m 2016 si vous
attendez forcément de rome d'avoir du
travail mais il ya aussi doute
spécificités dont les y viennent 2016
2016 c'est une année charnière pour le
pour les chambres de métiers en général
puisque nous avons été sous le couvert
aussi de la régionalisation pour
mutualiser des fonctions support donc ça
ça nous prend du temps de l'énergie ça
crée un climat de suspicion vis-à-vis de
nos agents puisqu'il n'y a pas trop de
visibilité une fois vous savez que quand
on fait de la régionalisation ça veut
dire faire des économies donc ça nous
verse dans un climat suspicieux
vis-à-vis de nos agents et sain et même
nous malgré que l'on soit très vigilant
on a du mal à avancer en bonne voie mais
néanmoins on avait justement par la
régionalisation à ceci on a bien sûr été
déjà impacté mêmes écrêté comme nos amis
de la chambre de commerce dans les
fonctionnements de chambre de métiers
d'un gros manque pour vous weepu
circulaire en chiffres si vous voulez le
souci pour le fonctionnement d'une
chambre des chambres de métiers
maintenant c'est que on use et crêtes
les subsides et qui reste au dessus de 4
mois et demi de fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous laisse
uniquement de quoi fonctionner avec
quatre mois d'avancé points il y a aucun
aucun prévisionnel d'investissements
possibles et en sachant que nous avons
sur le 60 18 spécifiquement notre
problème de cfa qui l'a dont les projets
sont sont remaniés à chaque coup mais je
n'ai pas de pour l'instant de projet
concret et là dessus a vraiment falloir
qu'on travaille dessus puisque 2016 la
loi de l'accessibilité va s'imposer
aussi chez nous et pour l'instant je
n'ai aucune réponse pour 900 apprentis
du cev
vous parliez de cfa justement la
formation d'apprentissage ça reste quand
même le cheval de bataille
l'apprentissage faut savoir que 70 % de
nos artisans sont issus de
l'apprentissage
on met en avant l'apprentissage pour le
moment c'est la voie royale
c'est la voie royale si on lui donne les
possibilités nous formons nos chambres
de métiers 30 % des apprentis au niveau
national sur l'île de france on forme
10000 apprentis par contre on en a pas
les moyens de les former donc on prend
de l'argent des artisans pour financer
nos cfa en pleine régionalisation est en
pleine taxe d'apprentissage
cet impôt qui a été pour les niveaux iv
et les niveaux 3 maintenant sert pour
l'ensemble des filières y compris les
filières niveau de niveau 1
donc tout le monde puise dans ses
et danser dans cette taxe est nous qui
cet axe qui était destiné donc à nos
niveaux nous avons nous touchons plus
elles toucheront plus et axa la cette
taxe à la au niveau nécessaire pour
faire de la bonne formation
donc c'est leur un premier problème
deuxième problème faut savoir que chaque
année on y perd dans 10 % d'apprentis
pourquoi compères 10 % puisque c'est
dommage mais il nous faut une catégorie
de jeunes qu'ils aient envie de venir
dans nos métiers notamment nous avons
les portes ouvertes qui se font un nom
du général mangin le 6 février et que
les jeunes viennent se voir
éventuellement s'ils sont intéressés par
nos métiers et nous formerons comme ça
nous nos successeurs et nos partenaires
pour les années à venir vous donne
également on vit voilà de se tourner et
d'artisanat par le biais de concours que
vous organisez c'est il ya de plusieurs
concours qui sont reconduits encore
cette année
je pense notamment à artisans 2020 aussi
à l'édition stars et métiers vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus et bien
l'ensemble de ces concours c'est pour
valoriser pour mettre en avant dans
certaines fonctions nos artisans puisque
l'artisanat c'est une dynamique au
quotidien et faut qu'on essaye de gérer
des artisans moteur pour montrer le
dynamisme néanmoins dans diverses dans
diverses métier c'est pour ça que ces
concours sont à la pub pour pouvoir
mettre en avant nos artisans alors le
concours artisans 2020 c'est jusqu'au
1er avril ce qu'on avait c'est ça oui je
lui bon comme il faut ça pour s'inscrire
sur le participer allez sur le site de
la chambre des métiers en étant artisan
bien sûr vous allez sur le site de la
chambre de métiers vous aurez tout
l'argumentaire pour proposer pour mettre
en avant votre maison il ya déjà eu
plusieurs meilleurs ouvriers de france
plusieurs artisans yvelinois distinguer
donc en 2015 notamment je pense
notamment à ludovic bisou qui était au
fromage et ou encore stéphane
milliasseau qui était le meilleur
ouvrier de france pour la protéger east
prothésiste dentaire vous attendez à
également est pris comme ça cette année
alors
déjà les meilleurs ouvriers de france et
tous les quatre ans c'est vrai que cette
année nous avons eu sur le département
huit récipiendaires sur les fruits
récipiendaires nous avons quatre jeunes
qui étaient issus de notre centre de
formation de versailles ils ont commencé
comme comme apprenti avec un ca pays que
ça soye le prothésiste soit il
esthéticienne enfin les 4 et était issu
du cfa de versailles ils ont progressé
ils ont eut ils ont été entourés de deux
collègues pour monter dans les dents les
échelons si vous voulez ça a été une
grande satisfaction de pouvoir priver
ces quatre récipiendaires avec
l'ensemble de ses huit 8 personnes merci
beaucoup à daniel var était devenu en
plateau et d'avoir répondu à notre
question jaune nous question je vous le
rappelle si vous voulez plus
d'informations sur les différents
concours artisans 2020 et aussi la 10e
édition de stars et métiers vous faire
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site internet www.cm tirer yvin poids à
faire le bandeau s'affiche en bas de
votre écran merci à vous faut et
l'estaca fête ses 90 ans cette année si
l'école située à saint quentin en
yvelines vient d'ouvrir ses portes en
septembre 2015
ce n'est qu'un déménagement car l'estac
aka également des locaux à laval a été
fondée en 1925 par rené bardin un
anniversaire fêté vendredi dernier
autour des thèmes chers à
l'établissement comme l'innovation et la
mobilité regarder quatre-vingt dix ans
après sa création l'objectif reste le
même pour l'estac à former des étudiants
passionnés par les transports la
nouveauté c'est leur donner le goût
d'entreprendre et ce n'est pas nicolas
guy qui dira le contraire cet ancien
élève a fondé sa start-up soyouz une
agence de conseil aujourd'hui il vient
partager son expérience
busta cas ça a été ma première école je
suis aujourd'hui assez content que
l'école lors de son implantation
à saint quentin en yvelines puisse
justement aujourd'hui ouvrir une filière
dédiée à l'entrepreneuriat
cela va permettre justement de pouvoir
susciter l'envié aux jeunes de l'école
une nouvelle filière créé pour
l'anniversaire de l'école est épaulé par
des professionnels du secteur privé on
est intéressé par les croisements entre
différentes cultures différentes écoles
à l'échelle du plateau de saclay c'est
une école ouverte sur son écosystème sur
ses partenaires collaborer avec des
acteurs du monde de l'entreprise et
s'ancrer dans le nouveau paysage local
illinois font partie des ambitions de
l'établissement un des projets phares
sur lesquels nous nous travaillons
aujourd'hui avec l'institut vd comme
tourner à la mise en place d'un véhicule
autonome
l'école a vu son taux d'inscription
augmenté de 25% pour l'année en cours
l'estaca qui compte aujourd'hui 1800
étudiants espère en accueillir 2000 à la
prochaine rentrée
et comme à chaque lundi c'est l'heure de
notre rendez vous culture nous
accueillons sephora namani bonsoir
sephora aujourd'hui floral art et nous
parler musique
oui tout à fait parce que se déroulait
samedi soir dernier à la salle paul
gauguin de montigny le bretonneux la
troisième édition du tremplin the choice
alors je rappelle que tous les groupes
yvelinois et pouvaient déposer en fait
leur maquette en début d'année et donc
une sélection a été faite cette
sélection était organisée par la ville
de montigny le bretonneux et l'intérêt
social université de saint quentin en
yvelines
marquisat co responsable du secteur de
musiques amplifiées de montigny le
bretonneux nous rappelle le principe de
ce tremplin
l'idée c'est de m
en compétition entre guillemets des
groupes des yvelines donc il ya une
présélection qui a été fait et il ya
donc quatre groupes qui ont été retenus
et le groupe qui sera sélectionné par le
public et par le jury puisqu'il ya 2
deux modes de vote fera la première
partie d'un groupe professionnel qui
sera programmé à la salle jacques brel
dans la prochaine saison
le tremplin a donc eu lieu samedi à la
salle paul gauguin de montigny le
bretonneux qu'elle était un petit peu
les critères de sélection alors
nécessairement il fallait une émotion
dans la musique un contact avec le
public de l'énergie bien sûr une
originalité dans les textes quatre
groupes étaient en lice ce soir là nous
sommes allés demander à certains d'entre
eux quelles étaient leurs atouts pour
réussir parmi eux le groupe pentatonique
spécialiste du rock français pour nous
l'efficacité tout à fait c'est d'avoir
une chanson là où le refrain on va se
coucher le soir à qui on va l'avoir
encore dans la tête et avec des textes
en français
saint-julien signe de l'une de nos
priorités en fait dans la composition
c
alors le groupe et la musique me parle
un petit peu il répète à guyancourt
c'est ça je pense qu'on avait fait un
sujet sur ces thèmes vous c'est fois
qu'ils en disent des charges est tout à
fait flora nous vous avez l'oeil
donc chaque groupe en général répète une
fois par semaine en studio de répétition
avec une vraie volonté de
professionnalisation par mu également on
avait le groupe élastique ce trio pour
du rock gaulois on a pas mal de textes
humoristiques
voilà donc il fallait tout trouver une
touche humoristique ce n'est allé à
voile ça s'est fait naturellement du
rock énergique sociale
s'ensuivent
et
et enfin il y avait également le groupe
et firent avec des textes profonds et
une écriture abouti en recherche fini 2e
dans un cadre musical entre nous créer
une musique la musique de zephy et en
même temps l'unité on cherche aussi dans
le visuel parce que c'est pas uniquement
la musique aujourd'hui en musique on a
besoin de visuels c'est très très
important et donc on essaye d'être un
peu de penser on peut sur tous les plans
il
et alors sephora qui a donc été le grand
gagnant de ce tremplin alors le grand
gagnant c'était le groupe zéphyr des
derniers groupes que vous avez pu voir à
l'image
l'enjeu pour eux était important qu'est
ce qu'ils vont gagner oui l'enjeu et et
pourront parce qu'à la clé bien sûr le
plaisir de monter sur scène gagner de la
visibilité et pourquoi pas même une
certaine forme de notoriété faire la
première partie ça c'était vraiment le
la récompense d'un groupe connu lors de
la prochaine saison artistique de
montigny le bretonneux première partie à
la salle jacques brel est également ils
le pourront effectuer différentes
résidences artistiques étaient
d'ailleurs invités les finalistes sur
scène en première partie les guest de
cette édition le groupe red wings et
nous sommes allé leur demander justement
tout le chemin parcouru depuis leur
dernière finale déjà en ambassadrice et
surtout et surtout au niveau musical on
a vachement évolué on est plus propre on
a des choses plus aboutie on est en été
- après citation pour créer nos morceaux
donc on a vraiment eu ce pas d'évolution
ça nous a aidé pour les concerts etc
donc c'est beaucoup même une belle
évolution je pense va travailler tout ce
qui est base rythmique donc travaillé au
tempo beaucoup plus rapides beaucoup
plus lent penser qu'on a fait des décors
et des cours de guitare à parent
également un prof de guitare qui est
venu une fois donné des conseils
d'arrangements et un prof de chant qui
est venue surtout pour les jeunes pour
travailler la voix
et puis après on a jouer jouer jouer et
on a surtout travaillé le jeu de scène
merci beaucoup à sephora pour cette
chronique que je rappelle que pour tous
ceux qui voudraient participer à de
chase une nouvelle édition sera
reconduite l'année prochaine
avis aux amateurs et nous continuons
maintenant sur la culture le festival
odyssée en yvelines une biennale de
création théâtrale à destination de la
jeunesse six pièces ont proposé aux
enfants et aux adolescents jusqu'au 2
avril à travers le département soit un
peu plus de 200 représentations pour
cette dixième édition des
représentations aussi bien dans les
salles de spectacle que dans les
médiathèques ou les établissements
scolaires ainsi ce samedi
la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt
proposé de la poésie mystique personne
du 12e siècle le cantique des oiseaux
une quête initiatique pour ces volatiles
fatigué de la confusion régnant dans le
monde est partant à la recherche d'un
être majestueuse regardez un extrait je
suis celui qui voit le désordre du
mais qui au même instant contemple sa
beauté son bistrot sa magie qui suis-je
le poète un sac à verre isolé jeu s'est
dessiné les paysages intérieurs avec des
fils invisibles
j'aime écouter le silence le bruissement
des feuilles et la mélodie des étoiles
suffisent à remplir mon coeur de joie
d'abord le jeune public c'est public de
demain voilà alors on lui qui pensons
que le théâtre joue joue comme la
culture un rôle essentiel dans la
construction même dans la construction
des citoyens évidemment s'adresser à
l'enfance à la jeunesse ça me semble
tout à fait essentiel et ce soir c'est
la reprise sur m6 de top chef l'émission
culinaire réuni un jury de quatre grands
chefs étoilés exigences et rigueur sont
au programme pour les 16 candidats
sélectionnés de cette 7e édition
parmi eux xavier pincemin versailles et
et sous chef du restaurant gordon ramsay
le restaurant deux étoiles du trianon
palace sephora namani et mélanie poté
ont rencontré celui qui sera peut-être
le futur gagnant de l'émission regardez
xavier pincement 26 ans d'origine
versaillaise et le sous chef des
cuisines du gordon ramsay le restaurant
deux étoiles du trianon palace hôtel
dans lequel il travaille depuis cinq ans
la cuisine une passion héritée de sa
mère son mentor son chef actuel l'étoile
et simoni zanoni je rencontrais simonet
zanoni la première fois en arrivant au
trianon palace tout de suite je me suis
rendu compte que c'était quelqu'un de
très exigeant je pense qu'il aime bien
transmettre son métier aux jeunes et
pour nous faire remonter le plus vite
possible
et puis en plus j'ai découvert à nu un
nouveau style de cuisine
c'était vraiment pour moi une cuisine
s'apprend infos que j'ai dans un gastro
il a joué les assiettes pour moi c'était
magnifique
lui dit qu'elle c'est ça que je veux
faire la cuisine gastronomique nécessite
exigences et rigueur et journée démarre
à 8 heures pour la mise en place et se
termine à une heure du matin à la fin du
service
vous aviez pincement dirige une brigade
de douze cuisiniers une expérience
qualifiante qui a donné envie à son chef
simonet annoni de l'inscrire au concours
top chef
quand j'ai appris qu'il m'avait inscrit
ça m'a touché je me suis dis bah oui la
confiance en moi et ça m'a fait plaisir
je dis bon moi j'ai pas fait sept ans de
travail avec avec ce chef là pour rien
c'est que voilà il ya quand même une
certaine reconnaissance
ce serait que ce mot n'est pas un chef
qui va te le dire qui va dire oui bravo
super ce que tu as fait beaucoup
maintenant ce que la sauce super 2000
top chef et pour xavier pincement un des
meilleurs concours culinaire médiatisé
une façon de partager sa passion avec
ses proches et de montrer de quoi il est
capable
un mois et demi de tournage viennent de
se terminer bilan de l'expérience très
positif c'était très prenant mais
beaucoup d'émotion et c'est vrai que
c'était assez difficile
on se remet deux fois en question moi
par exemple sur les desserts c'est vrai
que je prends un pâtissier c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait que je mette plus là le
nez en pâtisserie message les compris ça
c'est grâce à top chef la diffusion de
top chef démarre lundi 25 janvier sur m6
la finale reste encore à tourner la
participation de xavier pincemin reste
un secret suspense oblige
voulait 10 25 janvier sur m6 et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie nous avoir suivis tout de suite
vous avez rendez vous avec michael almy
d'euros pour le cfid sport quant à moi
je vous retrouve demain je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée